welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is my reaction and
breakdown of Marvel's Guardians of the
Galaxy holiday special trailer this
being the latest Marvel special
presentation streaming on Disney Plus on
November 25th that's Black Friday now I
love werewolf by night and I am really
digging these hour-long dips into the
MCU just before my theories started to
get pruning and wrinkly so let us react
to this trailer and then break down the
big stuff that you might have missed in
it he we
[Music]
I just saw on the calendar that right
now on Earth it's almost Christmas time
we don't have time for trivialities like
Christmas but that's me at work
oh
really
oh no oh
it's so sweet
[Music]
special how old is Greer
[Music]
we're looking for the legendary Kevin
Bacon looking for the legendary Kevin
Bacon
I think maybe he didn't hear you
oh my God
you're coming with us as a Christmas
present
ah this is gonna be great
Cosmo
are they just saw trampolines
oh yes I would have spend every
Christmas with the MCU last year Hawkeye
was a lot of fun a lot of those episodes
very Christmassy and this is like the
the sweetest kind of MCU Christmas Story
I could imagine it's just the other
Guardians wanting to give Peter Quill a
nice Christmas because he misses Gamora
but also these extraterrestrials having
no sense of what Christmas is and let's
be honest it's probably not only going
to be a sweet Christmas nostalgic trip
for Peter Quill because he misses Gamora
it's gonna be because he misses his
family back in Missouri now as with
werewolf By Night a big question for a
lot of people were how Canon is this how
connected is it to the MCU how essential
is it to watch well I think everything
with the Marvel Studios title in front
of it's essential but where do I need my
knight actually had some pretty
significant ties with the MCU I think
we're gonna see I mean in introducing
characters like man thing Elsa
Bloodstone Jack Russell obviously going
to show up in horror titles in the
future things like blade and the
midnight suns in this case we're meeting
Kevin Bacon in the MCU the only downside
of that is now Kevin Megan can't really
play an actor in the MCU it's kind of
like David Hasselhoff well I guess
you're not playing an MC villain anymore
unless they want to recast them or to
like disguise them under Prosthetics and
make up a VFX so where in the MCU
timeline does this story take place well
obviously it must take place after
Avengers end game because you know
they're missing Gamora they were all
dusted during the blip and then endgame
ended with uh Gamora at least from
another timeline going her own separate
ways really the clock here that we're
looking at is Groot Groot is definitely
beefier and bigger than when we saw him
in Avengers end game he's bigger than
when we saw him in Thor love and thunder
his voice is deeper there was some
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 footage that
was shown at d23 I think Guardians of
the Galaxy Christmas special is set
before Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3.
Bird's facial structure doesn't change
that much it looks like the teenager's
head on just like a body closer to what
he looked like in the first Guardian of
the Galaxy but he's definitely thicker
like remember Groot in the first
Guardians of the Galaxy was pretty
stringy and thin now our man has not
been skipping any days at the gym but I
mean how does like a tree add muscle
mass now look at my hair it looks
healthy right like healthy enough that
you might be thinking hang on Eric did
you send your hair to a spot for a
weekend getaway well the answer is no oh
I did not my hair is healthy thanks to
geology I know you're all thinking
geology isn't that the 13 times
award-winning skin care company with
over 5000 five-star reviews well yes
they are but now they also do hair and
I'm super excited about it geology has a
new custom control hair care line with
brand new co-wash co-wash is the
anti-shampoo shampoo strips your hair of
the essential oils the scalp produces
and can leave your hair drying or scalp
dry too typical shampoos use harsh
chemicals to clean your hair but co-wash
uses friction and scrubbing motion to
remove the dirt and grime from your
scalp keeping your hair clean and
healthy without damaging it in the
process because good air comes from
having a healthy scalp co-wash focuses
on cleansing and nourishing the scalp
removing the buildup and cleansing the
hair without big lather harsh
ingredients or stripping the hair of its
natural oils co-wash puts you 100 in
control if you're clean based on how
much product you use how long you use it
and how often you apply it I think it's
co-wash I do skin care for your scalp
and your hair because ultimately Hair
Care is skincare geology hair products
are great for all hair types and are
color safe and you can either get a
cooling co-wash with tea tree and aloe
or a smoothing co-wash with avocado and
coconut I'm a tea tree and aloe kind of
guy why because you can never be too
cool to celebrate the launch of their
new product they are hooking you up with
this unbelievable special offer click
the link below to get 70 off a skincare
trial but not only that you use the
second link to take an additional 15 off
the new co-wash which is already 15 off
for the pre-order you're not going to
want to miss this offer I like that
Cracklin has this conversation about
looking at the calendar on Earth to
figure out what time Earth is on
relative the rest of the universe
because this is a rare example of like
time and relativity being acknowledged
in the MCU like it doesn't make sense
that you know other plants would have
the same day and night scheduled as what
would be on earth realistically what
would happen is probably what we see in
the interstellar you'd have some planets
that are just completely time dilated
out of whack compared to Earth but in
this case they're all relatively on the
same calendar it's just they don't have
things like Christmas off-world which
would make sense except there was a god
of carpentry in omnipotent City and
throw love and thunder so theoretically
there might be Christians that exist off
Earth in the MCU dragon has head to the
Hollywood home of Kevin Bacon whom they
know Peter Quill is pretty obsessed with
Kevin Bacon came up as like a hero that
Peter very much admired during Infinity
War the star of movies like Footloose
now a question I have is what ship are
Drax and mantis taking to Earth because
it doesn't look like the Benetar it
actually looks like it kind of opens up
and then folds in on itself as it
navigates this asteroid belt through the
UNT end that's kind of like the
universal hyperspace jumping grid that
allowed them to go from Galaxy to Galaxy
Cosmo the space dog is returning from uh
the first Guardians of the Galaxy movie
he was in the collector's Vault he did
make it out before the whole place
exploded good to see now ultimately yes
this does really just seem like a
wholesome Christmas Adventure but if we
think about it this an adventure
orchestrated by mantis she is an empath
she can sense other people's emotions
and that has like a tactical function in
these stories like the fact that Peter
is depressed might be an issue that is
blocking all of the rest of the team
like they're not able to take a specific
gig or there's some mission that because
Peter's just not up for for it it's
holding them back honestly my hope for
this is that Kevin Bacon can just join
the MCU as Kevin Bacon and that future
MCU titles can just have Kevin Bacon as
someone who exists on earth like it
could be someone who ties into secret
invasion is Kevin Bacon replaced by a
scroll Kevin Bacon can show up in uh
King Dynasty or Secret Wars or Loki or
She-Hulk season two Kevin Bacon could
just be someone that they check in with
or get some advice you can show up in
cameos they'll wait Stan Lee would just
kind of show up in cameos that way
future MCU titles can just kind of have
fun with what they want to establish
about Kevin Bacon in the MCU reality
could he be like a vampire could it be
any internal who exists on Earth could
it be a mutant just someone who
discovers that they're mutant and we get
to play with that now going forward now
when we first learned at this title
James Gunn has said that he's a big fan
of Star Wars holiday special and wanted
to go for something that has a similar
vibe in the MCU and if you look back at
the Star Wars holiday special that story
was really about Chewie trying to get
home to his home world and his family to
celebrate life day there's a similar
thing happening here they were just
trying to take one character who's
bummed that he can't be with his loved
ones and trying to just give him one
nice day and he has a lot of goofy
things and jokes and hygiene and dance
sequences are going to be part of it as
well I think we're all really going to
enjoy it I can't wait to see this on
November 25th of course we're going to
be doing a breakdown of it because we
break down everything in the MCU you can
follow me on Tick Tock Instagram and
Twitter at avos subscribe to new
rockstars follow new Rockstar and social
media thank you for watching see you
next time bye
[Music]